au quartier général du parti et ayari
charbit il règne comme un calme
inhabituel depuis le coup de force du
président sayed le 25 juillet dernier
malgré le gel de l'activité du parlement
et l'interruption de la participation
des partis politiques aux règles
nationales
certaines formations reconnaissent la
nécessité d'un changement en profondeur
du système politique tunisien un
changement qui leur semblent être
incarnée par l'homme fort de la tunisie
kaïs sayed le parti taillard chaâbi et
rassuré par ce gouvernement d'après 25
juillet plusieurs raisons
ce gouvernement je soutiens du peuple
tunisien contrairement à ceux d'après
2011 qui étaient pour la plupart issus
de complot et d'arrangements politiques
de plus ils pas des moindres c'est une
femme qui est à la tête de ce nouveau
gouvernement
une première dans le monde arabe sans
parler du fait qu'une grande partie sont
des femmes
je pense que cette nuit du 25 juillet
kaïs ayed il nous a remis sur les rails
de la démocratie une démocratie ne
devrait pas avoir de parti politique qui
se font les porte paroles du terrorisme
où des puissances étrangères
heureuse de voir une femme à la tête du
gouvernement ou ata bellaïd reste
prudente membre du bureau exécutif du
parti d'affi à tournai elle attend des
actes forts de la part du président de
la république a commencé par une
clarification de sa feuille de route et
un retour au dialogue avec les partis
politiques
seule condition selon elle au maintien
des acquis démocratiques de la
dévolution de 2011 le partenariat tonné
ça écrit et bien sûr avec satisfaction
la nomination du gouvernement tout en
sachant que depuis le 25 juillet nous
étions sans gouvernement et avaient
aussi la suspension du parlement c'est
une revendication de la classe politique
ce gouvernement est caractérisée par la
nomination d'une femme chef de
gouvernement c'est une première tunisie
le soir très fier de cette nomination au
partenariat donner ce gouvernement nous
devons les soutenir parce que c'est là
peut-être la dernière chance est un
gouvernement qui va nous permettre de
passer de cette période transitoire vers
une nouvelle période plus stable avec la
reprise du fonctionnement des
différentes institutions de l'état nous
attendons dans ce cadre que le président
de la république nous précise le la
durée de ces mesures exceptionnelles qui
ont été prises dont comptant dix corps
et nous demandons au président de la
république de de faire participer les
indifférents intervenants à ceux à ce
dialogue disons aux à ce nouveau système
politique comme d'autres membres de
l'opposition le parti taya démocratique
dénonce la nomination d'un gouvernement
aux prérogatives réduit mise en place
pour servir le projet d'un seul homme au
détriment de réelle orientation et d'un
programme au service du pays
puis le 25 juin caractérise la politique
du président kaïs saïed c'est de sortir
progressivement de la constitution avec
comprend culminant évidemment le 22
septembre et sa décision de suspendre la
constitution et de la remplacer par une
organisation provisoire des pouvoirs il
ne peut pas prétendre les lui
qui compte par ailleurs amender la
constitution
de son propre chef ni à mener une
réforme politique de grande envergure
sans dialogue sans discussions avec les
parties prenantes je ne m'attends
honnêtement pas à ce qu'un gouvernement
qui ait choisi de travailler
soul empire de la décision du 22
septembre pour
resterez les quelques acquis de la
démocratie qui ont été vraiment violé
ces derniers temps il ya aussi une autre
première à noter c'est que c'est la
première chef du gouvernement en tunisie
à
noeuds ça mais à ne jamais s'exprimer
qui a été on va dire spolié de sa voix
et qui a été aussi spolié de ses
pouvoirs qui sont inscrits dans la
constitution donc c'est bien d'eux
d'avoir nommé une femme chef du
gouvernement on aurait aimé que ce soit
dans de meilleures circonstances et que
l est les mêmes prérogatives que ses
prédécesseurs
don à la casbah et qu'elle est surtout
une voix une politique une vision pour
la tunisie ce que visiblement elle n'a
pas encore réussi à nous transmettre
dans une tunisie fragilisé criblé de
dettes émises à terre par des années de
mauvaise gestion kaïs ier ne semble
toujours pas prêt à accorder sa
confiance à une classe politique qui
considèrent comme profondément corrompu
malgré la nomination d'un gouvernement
que réclamait l'opposition et la
puissante centrale syndicale ugtt était
le président de la république demeure à
ce jour en vertu des mesures
exceptionnelles le réel détenteur du
pouvoir exécutif dans le pays